sophie turner and joe jonas are
officially parents
that's right i'm so excited about it a
rep for the couple confirmed to e.t that
the 24 year old actress gave birth to
the couple's first child together
with a source adding that it's a girl
et's source opened up about the bundle
of joy revealing that the two
are over the moon quote the couple is
already obsessed and can't stop bloating
about their new addition
the couple is taking time to enjoy this
special moment and have only shared the
news and updates with family and friends
the source adds that with the
coronavirus pandemic
joe and sophie have been very cautious
about who was around them
and their little girl just like the best
support the best person to calm me down
and keep me calm according to tmz the
couple named their little bundle of joy
willa sophie and joe have been dating
since 2016.
you posted a picture of mr joe jonas on
instagram people called it instagram
official
uh i don't know he seems pretty good
what do you like about spending time
with him
uh we go eat some really good food
together
we eat nice brussels sprouts got engaged
in 2017
just love and be loved and tied the knot
in a surprise wedding in vegas in 2019
but they've been pretty private during
her pregnancy news first broke
that sophie was expecting in february
but the two never
officially confirmed it and even though
they were tight-lipped so
didn't shy away from showing off for a
growing baby bump in public
we're having a good time i mean like you
know we got married last year so
we're we're new to this so we're still
enjoying that time and also we're on
tour for
what seems like more than a year so uh
being home is is kind of nice
in may joe opened up about spending time
with his wife while under quarantine
during an interview with siriusxm
hits one's celebrity session hosted by
the morning mash-up
we also appreciate you know and know
that the time
for for ourselves is important so like
i'll do my thing she does her thing even
though we're on
under one roof i think that's that's
been helpful for us and in april sophie
echoed all of that during an appearance
on conan everything
seems to be working out in my favor here
because
joe's like a he's a real social
butterfly so
i struggle to kind of lock him down and
have him just spend time with me so it's
kind of it's like prison for him but
it's
great for me